traffic in and out of the area as  manageable as possible by the way the  nevada department of transportation says  there will not be any lane restrictions  through the ongoing construction there  where the 15 meets the northern 215  beltway so that's good while a lot of  people do take the i-15 straight up to  the speedway there are some better  alternatives depending on where you're  coming from so from the far west the  northwest and northern parts of the  valley you'd be much better off just  jumping on the 215 all the way over to  the 15. from northeast clark county  obviously it makes sense to take the 15  that's about the only way they can get  there  meanwhile for the southeast valley  henderson boulder city try i-11 95-515  to las vegas boulevard skip the freeway  take las vegas boulevard all the way to  speedway entry number three  buckle up drive carefully please put  down that phone something's driving you  crazy you can email me traffic 8 8 news  now dot com